النمو البدايه من التطورات في السودان حيث
بدا في السادسه من صباح اليوم بالتوقيت
المحلي سريان اتفاق لوقف القتال في كل
ارجاء البلاد لمده 24 ساعه وذلك برعايه
سعوديه امريكيه هذا وافاد مراسلنا بسماع
ذوي اطلاق نار متقطع في العاصمه بعد بدء
سريان الهدنه كما شوهدت عمله الدخان
تتصاعد في سماء المدينه وافاد مراسلنا ان
الطائرات الحربيه قصفت قبل دقائق من بدء
سريان الهدنه الجديده موقعا جنوب الخرطوم
بحري بينما ردت المضادات الارضيه على
القصف
يستمر تصاعد اعمده الدخان مع استمرار
الحرائق لليوم الرابع على التوالي في
منشاه للنفط والغاز عقب هجوم على مجمع
اليرموك العسكري للصناعات الدفاعيه جنوبيه
الخرطوم
انضم الينا من شرق الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
اسامه السيد احمد اسامه اهلا بك اذا ما
مدى الالتزام بالهدنه حتى اللحظه وفيما
تختلف عن سابقاتها
نعم بدخول الهدنه الذي التي تم الاتفاق
عليها ما بين الطرفين كل من الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه هذه الهدنه
دخلت حيز التنفيذ عند الساعه السادسه
صباحا اليوم بتوقيت السودان اي قبل نحو
ثلاث ساعات من الان يعني قبل دخول حيز
تنفيذ لهدنه اليوم الواحد كان هناك قصف
بالطيران الحربي لاحد المواقع جنوب
الخرطوم وسمعت الدوي اطلاق المضادات
الارضيه التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع هذه
قبل دقائق فقط قبل دخول حيز التنفيذ لهذه
الهدنه هدنه اليوم الواحد ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم نستمع لاييي صوت من اصوات
الاجتماعي يشير الى وجود اشتباكات في اي
مكان هناك هدوء حذر في كل الجبهات القتال
في كل الجبهات المعتاده وليست المعتاده
كذلك لم نستمع لاي مواجهات مباشره او غير
مباشره سوى بعض الطلقات في الهواء متفرقه
هنا وهناك طبعا هناك مواقف يعني مرحبه
بهذه الخطوه خطوه الهدنه اليوم واحد من
الجهات عديده وقبلها كان هناك التزام من
الجيش السوداني بهذه الهدنه وكذلك من قوات
الدعم السريع المواقف يعني متعدده المواقف
السياسيه فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والمرحب بها من جهات عديده داخليه هنا
يعني مثلا حزب الامه القومي رحب بهذه
الهدنه وعبر عن تطلعها
تتطور هذه المباحثه المباحثات ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لتشمل
وقفا دائما
اطلاق النار وكذلك تسهيل عمليات الاصاله
للمساعدات الانسانيه للمحتاجين في كل مكان
في الخرطوم وفي الولايات كذلك
قوه اعلان الحريه والتغيير مجموعه المجلس
المركزي ايضا رحبت بهذه الهدنه لاربع
وعشرين ساعه ما بين الجانب الجانب الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وعبرت عن املها ان تشمل المباحثات الحوار
لان يفضي
لاتفاق جديد يشمل وقفا دائما لاطلاق النار
خاصه وان الوضع الانساني بدا متفاقما يوما
بعد يوم وقالت ان الاستمرار القتال في
السودان هدد كيان الدوله باكملها ويجب ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب في اسرع وقت ممكن
وبالتالي هناك يعني
يعني
مرحب كثيرا بهذه الخطوه الرئيس لجنه
الاتصال بقوه اعلان الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي كذلك يرى ان هدنه
اليوم الواحد لمده 24 ساعه لا تكفي
لكسر حده ما وصفها بالكارثه خاصه فيما
يتعلق باعاده الخدمات للمستشفيات وكذلك
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للولايات وكذلك
يعني اعاده الخدمات فيما يتعلق بالمياه
والكهرباء الخدمات التي تتعلق مباشره
بالمواطنين وبالتالي ايضا عبر عن عمله ان
يكونوا ان تمدد هذه الهدنه شكرا جزيلا
لايام اخرى حتى تشمل وقفا دائما لاطلاق
النار شكرا لك